m
[Applaudissements]
du chocolat beaucoup de chocolat en vue
du temps des fêtes la période la plus
occupée de l'année pour le propriétaire
de l'entreprise newfoundland charts
company une entreprise locale en pleine
croissance mais dont l'expansion et
menaces y prennent ce mythe peine à
recruter des employés selon statistique
canada terre neuve et labrador est la
seule province au pays a enregistré un
déclin de sa population et pour l'aider
à relever son économie alors qu'elle est
la province la plus endettée par
habitant au canada
l'avenir de son entreprise repose donc
entre les mains magiques des migrantes
comme herlinda une philippine qui a
choisi terre-neuve comme terre d'accueil
ici 20 % des employés sont des
immigrants environ 2 5% de la population
de terre-neuve-et-labrador sont des
nouveaux arrivants selon statistique
canada
en proportion si dix fois moins qu'en
alberta
on cherche des employés partout comme
dans les chaînes de restauration
ironique alors que le taux de chômage de
terre-neuve-et-labrador aussi autour de
11% le plus élevé au pays
deux facteurs expliquent ce chiffre on a
besoin de travailleurs qualifiés et les
terre-neuvier sont habitués à des
salaires élevés croit nancy et les
difficultés des emplois au salaire
minimum qui accepte avec grand plaisir
le mari der linde a et son fils en âge
de travailler tous les deux sont à
l'emploi du restaurant a&w le plan de la
province pour attirer des nouveaux
arrivants comme la famille de linda
manque d'ambition selon certains le
gouvernement provincial se dit conscient
du problème et se félicite d'avoir
atteint 90% sa cible pour 2022
je crois aussi que la province devrait
être plus agressive pour attirer les
nouveaux arrivants ce qui aurait dû être
l'enjeu principal des deux dernières
campagnes électorales provinciales et
fédérales est passé sous le radar selon
lui
et brett tentent de les faire sentir
comme à la maison
car l'avenir de la grosse roche en
dépend et il espère pouvoir continuer à
faire goûter au plus de gens possible
ces chocolats ici elisa série radio
canada c'est jean terre neuve